TIM MURRAY: My name Tim Murray.
I'm from the Android
Performance Team.
And I'm going to talk about
Systrace, which we already
talked about a bit earlier,
with the system tracing
in Android Studio.
But I'm going to talk more
about the old style of looking
at traces, as well as what
you actually do with a trace.
So what are the big
performance goals for a game?
There are really two big ones.
Number one, you need to
get the game play fast.
The user has to wait 10, 20, 30
seconds to launch a game, then,
they're going to quit.
They're not going to be
happy with your game.
They're going to
find another game.
The other thing is, you need
to maintain interactivity
during gameplay.
It's great if you get to
the game to play fast.
But if the gameplay
is super janky,
dropping frames all over
the place, it's really bad.
So the problem is mobile
devices are really complicated.
You know, you look at a
current flagship phone
and it's an eight-core CPU
with heterogeneous CPU cores.
And there is a giant GPU.
And your flash performance is
totally different than what
you would expect on a PC.
There's a lot going on.
You really can't assume anything
about how your code runs.
I've been looking at
performance for years now.
I can't predict
how code will run.
No one should assume
how their code runs.
So that's why we have Systrace.
It shows you what
actually is running.
It is sort of truth,
capital T, Truth.
If Systrace says something
ran at a certain time,
it ran at a certain time.
You cannot lie to it.
You cannot trick it.
It's outputting events
from the kernel directly.
Whatever Systrace
says is happening
is actually happening,
which makes it really great.
The other great thing about
it, because it's so low level,
the overhead is basically zero.
We will just turn on
Systrace and let it stream
into a buffer, like
an in-memory buffer.
So you can get the last 10
or 20 seconds out of it.
It has no measurable overhead.
It's sub-1%.
So we do that.
And we find a ton of
performance bugs that way.
It's great.
So first of all, let's talk
about how to take a trace.
And I'm going to not talking
about the Android Studio
side of things, because we
already talked about that.
I'm going to talk about
the two other ways we
have to take a trace.
So first of all, most of
the tools for tracing, other
than Android Studio, exist
in this open source project
called Catapult. It's maintained
by people from the Android
team and the Chrome team.
And it lives on GitHub.
So you grab the Git
Repo for Catapult,
and you end up with a
Systrace Python binary in that
directory,
catapult/systrace/bin/systrace.
And that's the main
shell to using Systrace.
If you want to take a trace
from the command line,
essentially, you run that,
and you pass a bunch of,
they're called
tags, to Systrace.
And this will determine the kind
of output you get in the trace.
So here it's going to take
a trace containing schedule
information, so exactly what the
scheduler is doing at any given
time, CPU frequency and
CPU idle information,
some Android Activity
Manager and Window Manager
information, then a
bunch of information
about the graphic stack, and
then a bunch more things--
well, input is
useful for game devs,
but the other ones
aren't too useful.
Input shows you when an
actual touch event happens,
so that's really useful
for game developers.
The last three
options are not tags.
So -b is the buffer size.
The buffer size determines
how much you can actually
record in a trace.
So it's a per CPU
ring buffer in memory.
So here, this is in kilobytes.
So on this device, I
get 16 megs per CPU.
Generally, 10 megs or
so per CPU is totally
fine on a high-end device.
It depends how much
context switching you're
doing, because that is probably
what occupies the most space
most of the time.
You can get about--
I would say it's
about one meg gets you
about two seconds of a trace.
So you could record a
pretty long trace with this.
- t is an optional
argument that tells you how
long to record the trace for.
If you don't pass -t, you just
press Enter to stop the trace.
And then -o is where
to write the trace.
If you don't pass
-o, it defaults
to trace.html, which is
fine, but also very annoying
when you start taking
hundreds of traces
and they're all
named trace.html.
So here's the cool new
thing in Android P,
which is actually
incredibly useful.
So it's really annoying to have
to have your phone plugged in
to take a trace.
And most of Systrace
actually lives on the device.
The Systrace binary is
basically just talking
to device-side stuff.
So in Android P, we
made it so you can
take a trace from the device.
The great thing about
this is that you
turn on developer options and
you get this Quick Settings
tile.
Once you turn it on, you
can start taking a trace.
And it will stream into
that in-memory buffer.
So you can turn on a trace.
It has super low
overhead, so you can just
leave it on and do your
thing and play your game.
And then you see,
hey, that seemed
like it took a long
time, or hey, I just
dropped a bunch of frames.
You pull down Quick
Settings, stop the trace.
And you've just captured
exactly what the problem is.
And you can just pull it
off, or email it to yourself
and see what's going on.
It will pop up a
dialog that allows
you to email it or share it to
Drive, or Dropbox, or whatever.
It's also saved to the
device in data/local/traces
if you do want to
pull it off the ADB.
The only special thing about the
system tracing Quick Settings
approach is that they are
compressed on the device,
so you have to do some
post-processing with Systrace
and Catapult. And I think
Android Studio is adding
support for this soon, so you
can import to Android Studio
as well.
But you process with
the from_file argument.
And you will get a trace out
of it, a normal HTML trace.
So, OK, you've got a trace.
What do you do with a trace?
Because it's kind of a lot.
Well, let's go through
a pretty simple one.
And then we'll go
through some gaming ones.
So I don't know how
legible this is.
Systrace doesn't
really present well.
But essentially you have
a big timeline view here.
So I took a trace of
application startup,
I think calculator startup.
And at the top, there is
some basic information
about the overall state of
the device, this interactions
and alert stuff.
The kernel line is
where we can see
what is actually running
on every CPU core
at any particular time.
And then we start getting
into a lot of per thread
information below that
we'll go into more
detail about in a moment.
So there's a lot more info
than fits on the screen,
so it does scroll up and down.
So make sure you scroll.
You also can navigate
around the trace with WASD,
so A and D to move
left and right,
and W and S to zoom in and out.
You also have this palette,
this floating palette
that's at the upper right-hand
that contains four tools.
The first tool is the pointer.
The pointer lets you
click stuff in the trace
and see what it is.
So here I clicked one of
the calculator time slices.
And I now get more information
about that particular instance
that it was running in the
bottom half of the screen.
So I can see, here is its PID.
Here's the TID.
Here's the priority.
Here is how long it was
actually running on the CPU.
So you will use
the pointer a lot.
The other thing you
can do with the pointer
is you can select
a bunch of stuff.
You can just draw a rectangle.
And after you draw
the rectangle,
you get an aggregate view.
So you can look and see--
I don't know-- what was
running during this time.
And you can sort these
and the normal stuff
that you would expect.
The fourth tool on here is
called, I think, the ruler.
But essentially it allows you
to mark a section of the trace.
And you highlight it.
And you can now scroll up
and down the trace view.
And that highlight will remain.
So if I've dropped
the frame around here,
I need to go look around
the rest of the trace
to see what's going on,
you can highlight that
and scroll up and down and
know exactly where you are.
The second and third
things on the palette
are a panning tool
and a zooming tool,
but they're equivalent to WASD.
So you can use the
palette tools if you want.
You can use WASD if you want.
It doesn't really matter.
So if we scroll down, we can
see per thread information.
And we can see information about
each thread's current state.
So the first thing
that you'll see--
and it's hard to read.
And I apologize.
Do I have an arrow?
I do have an arrow.
So there's this stack of boxes.
So essentially the trace
sections for a given thread
are a stack.
So you'll say trace begin
section, activity start.
And then something else will
say trace begin section, inflate
for inflated view.
And so they appear as
a stack in the trace.
The other thing
that is at least as
important for reading a
trace is the multicolored bar
above each thread.
And you can see it.
It's hard to see.
But that tells you information
about the state of the thread
at any given time.
Oh, and you can see it
in more detail there.
So you can see there we've
got a bunch of green sections.
We've got some orange section.
We've got some red.
We've got some
blue, and sections
where it's just not colored.
So there's some green.
And if you actually
click that green bar,
it will tell you
that it was running.
And it will tell you
how long it was running
and which CPU it was running on.
So you can track your
thread's progress
through the system that way.
You can see, OK, it was
running here for this time,
and then it was blocked
on something else,
and then it woke up, and figure
out what's going on there.
So the different colors are--
there are five colors.
Number one is green.
That just means the
thread is running.
It's currently running on a CPU.
You know, it's actually making
progress during that time.
The only thing that could run
when a thread is in the running
state is an interrupt.
And that lasts sub-microsecond
most of the time.
So if your thread is running,
it's actually on the CPU,
doing work.
If it's runnable, that can
mean one of two things.
A thread will become runnable
when it's been sleeping
and something wakes it up.
Or if your thread is just--
let's say you have a spin loop,
just while one, do nothing,
eventually the
scheduler will say,
OK, you've exceeded
the amount of CPU time
you can have right now.
I'm going to de-schedule you
and let something else run.
Then your thread will
be made runnable,
in that it could be running.
There's nothing blocking
it from running,
but the scheduler has
not selected it to run.
The third state is sleeping.
Sleeping just means there's
no work for this thread to do,
so it's not running.
Usually it means
you're blocked on--
if you expect that
your thread should
be running but you
see it's sleeping,
it's probably actually
blocked on a mutex somewhere,
because block
contention in userspace
does show up as sleeping.
The last two are kinds of
sleep inside the kernel.
The orange is
uninterruptible sleep
in block I/O, which means
you are waiting on disk.
So if you see that
a lot, it means
you are loading a ton
of data from disk.
And maybe you shouldn't do that.
The last one, red, is
uninterruptible sleep.
This means you are blocked
somewhere else in the kernel.
It's probably not
I/O. It's probably
related to memory
management, because we
do see that the vast majority
of time in uninterruptible sleep
is actually because
of memory management.
And so a easy,
quick thing that I
do as the first part of
reading any trace is you
can select all of these
bars above a thread
and get an aggregate view.
So here I can see that
this particular thread was
sleeping for 12 milliseconds.
It was runnable for 0.6
milliseconds, running for 3.1.
You know, it looks totally
normal, totally fine.
But you can use this
to get a sense of where
your bottlenecks may be.
If your thread is always
running and you're still
not meeting your
performance targets,
you're probably CPU bound.
That's probably a good bet.
If you see that your thread
is sleeping and never running,
maybe there is some
lock contention.
Maybe you're waiting
on GPU activity.
The bottleneck is not
the CPU for that thread.
The bottleneck is
somewhere else.
If you're seeing a
ton of block I/O,
then you're probably
reading too much
from the disk at any given time.
And the thread
can't make progress
because it's waiting
for data from the desk.
So that's a good first check for
where your bottlenecks may be.
One other really helpful
thing here-- let me see,
do I have an arrow?
I do have an arrow.
Up at the very top, this
interactions and alerts area,
it's really hard to read,
but you can actually
see when the user touched
the screen, this input thing.
So you can tell, when you have a
trace and I tap the screen once
and something happened
that was slow,
this gives you a really
good way to orient yourself
in the trace.
You can tell, OK, well, the bad
behavior must be around here.
So one of the most important
things to do with a trace
is to add your own
trace sections.
You can debug a lot of
issues without having
your own trace sections,
where you as the app developer
know what your app
is trying to do.
But if you add your
own trace sections,
life gets so much easier.
It's really five
to 10 times faster
to debug if you have
your own trace sections.
So from Java, you
include this package.
It's trace.beginSection
and trace.endSection.
The only thing you have to
do is, because it is a stack,
you need to actually make
sure that every begin section
has an end section, otherwise
the trace gets really weird.
And it's bad.
And you won't like it.
But, of course, nobody in here
really cares that much about
Java, so for the NDK, you
include android/trace.h,
ATrace_beginSection,
ATrace_endSection.
And I believe that is
supported on API 23 and up.
So when you actually want
to take an app trace,
all you have to do
is you take a trace,
you add -a and
your package name.
And that will turn on
app tracing for your app.
And you will just get results.
There is a trace section
that I added to a random app
at one point.
And it just shows up as
any other trace session.
But it's really good
for when, say, you're
loading something, or
waiting on network activity,
you know semantically what
your app is attempting to do.
You can express that
information in a trace.
And combined with everything
the system thinks is going on,
you can get a much better
view of how your app performs.
OK, so game traces--
because that's why
we're here, let's
look at a couple
actual game traces.
So just out of curiosity, how
many people in here use Unity?
OK, a pretty large number.
What about Unreal?
OK, and what about custom
engines, not Unity or Unreal?
OK, cool.
So I took two traces each
from two popular games,
current top 20, maybe.
And I anonymized them
to not put them on edge.
And the first uses
a custom engine.
The second is a Unity game.
So let's look at that first one.
So this is app startup.
And I don't have my notes.
And that's really annoying.
So this is what it looks
like after I took to trace.
So I downloaded it on
a Pixel 2 XL running P.
And so I open it up.
And I can see--
so this was launching a game.
So at some point in
here I click the screen.
And I think you can see
that up at the very top
there is that one place
where the second row
in the interaction
section is lit up.
And that is where I
actually touched the screen.
So I started this game.
And I wanted to see, is it fast?
Is it good?
And it took a few seconds.
It wasn't too bad,
but, I thought
it could probably be better.
So here's the actual startup
section for the game.
And it looks a little weird,
because the UI thread is--
it's called the UI thread
in Catapult. It's actually
just the main thread.
It is the first thread,
so that starts up first.
That's where app
code usually runs.
The UI thread just goes idle for
a second in the middle there.
Actually, yeah, it's
1.4-ish seconds.
It just doesn't run anything.
It's asleep.
It's not waiting on anything.
I looked at other threads.
Nothing else was running.
That's weird.
If you look at what else
is running on the system,
it doesn't look--
it might not look that idle.
It's pretty idle.
There's some stuff running
at the beginning of that time
as probably rendering
the transition
to draw the window for the app.
But by the end,
nothing's running.
App is just waiting.
So we can go and see what
actually woke up the app.
And here I've zoomed in to the
very edge of that 1.4-second
time.
And there's a tiny,
little blue block
at the end of that where that
main thread becomes runnable.
And here I can see
wake up from TID zero.
And so wake up
from TID tells you
what thread made
something runnable, which
is really great, because you
can actually get into causation.
You can say, this thread caused
this other thing to happen.
And you know it's real.
It's true.
But TID zero means
it's an interrupt.
And that's really weird,
because apps usually
don't see interrupts directly.
The only interrupt
they ever really see
is a timer interrupt.
But let's just be careful, and
sure, and scroll up and look.
And, yeah, during the--
I don't know-- 20
or 30 milliseconds
before, there's
nothing really running.
And we don't have
interrupt latency
of 20 or 30 milliseconds.
That would be wild.
So I wonder if the app is
sleeping for 1.4 seconds.
I think it's possible.
This wouldn't show up on a
profiler, because you wouldn't
see sleep on a profiler.
But it really does look
like the app is just
sleeping during app startup.
So let's go on to
the next trace.
So this is gameplay.
And gameplay here, it has some
load screens in the middle.
And I wondered what was
happening during that time.
So a thing about
gameplay, and why I still
use Catapult instead
of Android Studio,
Catapult will show you every
process on the system, which
is a ton of data,
but it will also
show you things
like SurfaceFlinger.
And SurfaceFlinger is great.
And if you have no idea
what I'm talking about when
I say SurfaceFlinger, let's
talk about how a frame actually
makes it to the
display on Android.
So what is the basic
lifecycle of a frame?
Number one, apps
will render a frame.
So your game will
render a frame.
And it will send a message
to SurfaceFlinger saying,
I have a frame ready
for you to display.
SurfaceFlinger will
wake up every 60 hertz,
I guess, and figure out
which apps are visible.
And it will build a
list of all the frames
to be combined into a form that
the underlying hardware can
deal with.
So that list makes its way
to a vendor driver and vendor
hardware called the
hardware composer.
And it will take--
maybe you have
this status bar up,
or the Home and Back buttons.
And all of that
will get overlayed
and turn into one framebuffer.
And that final frame will
be sent to the display.
The great thing here is
that SurfaceFlinger tracks
every app and every frame.
So if we look at
SurfaceFlinger's state,
we can see exactly
what is arriving
when from any
particular application.
So let's go back
and look at gameplay
and look at SurfaceFlinger.
So here we have this line,
this surface view row.
And it's a counter.
So the surface view
is triple buffered.
So you either have zero frames
pending, or one or two frames.
And you can see it's
usually bouncing around,
which means we are getting
frames from the app.
But again, there's a gap here.
And it's about 700 milliseconds.
And the game does do
something with load screens.
So let's go see what the app is
doing, because this is probably
a load screen.
And here, yeah, we have
this long 700-millisecond
on-draw frame section.
And if we look and see what's
actually happening, yeah,
it's running for
about-- what is that--
190 milliseconds and sleeping
for 500-odd milliseconds.
So it's waiting on
other work to happen.
Now, there are these
other two threads nearby
that seem to be doing work.
What's up with them?
Well, they're
running, and sleeping,
and runnable for some of it.
Let's see, is that--
OK, yeah.
So if you actually look at
what these thread sections are,
they are tagged with IOmx,
which I know from other Android
things is sound stuff.
So I think what's
actually happening here
is the game is
pausing its loading--
or pausing displaying frames
in order to load more sounds.
But you can see before
this big loading section,
there's a lot of
free CPU cycles.
The game is not keeping
the device that busy.
This load screen can
probably be fixed and removed
completely just by moving a lot
of this loading ahead of time
to overlap with actual gameplay,
because there's enough CPU time
to do it.
So that's the kind of
stuff you can get out
of Systrace in less
graphically intensive games.
Now let's look at a really
graphically intensive game.
So this one uses Unity as well.
And let's see.
I think I have level start here.
And then we have
actual gameplay next.
So for my level
start trace, this
is what I see when
I first open it up.
And you can see the surface
view in the center there.
And it does have a big chunk
where SurfaceFlinger is not
displaying anything,
because no frames are really
arriving from the game.
And if we actually trace from--
highlight from where frames
are being consistently
delivered, in other
words, before I started
the level, to when they
are being consistently
delivered again--
that's probably after the game
is really displaying stuff--
it's about 5.7 seconds.
It's pretty long, as
a player, to see that.
So let's go see what the
game is actually doing.
So here is the
Unity main thread.
And the Unity main thread,
if you look at Unity apps,
you're going to be
looking at the Unity
main thread a whole lot.
But you can see it
is not super busy,
which is weird and not great.
So what is it actually doing?
Well, it's running
for-- what is that--
3.1 seconds.
And it's sleeping
for 2.5 seconds.
So what's actually
happening during this sleep?
So if we zoom in a lot--
and now we're looking at a
300-millisecond period that
you--
I saw this 300-millisecond
pattern repeat
kind of consistently throughout
this Unity main section.
You see that it runs for a
bit, and then goes to sleep,
and runs for a bit, and
goes to sleep, and repeat.
And it looks really periodic.
It looks like it's happening
on frame boundaries.
So let's see what's
actually waking it up.
So once again, we can zoom in.
And there's a tiny, little
blue bar that is probably not
visible from this.
But we can see the wake up from
TID 31526, which is something.
So we can go scroll up
to the top of the trace
now and figure out what that is.
Hey, it's the Unity
Choreographer thread.
So what I think
is happening here
is that the game is
running some Unity script.
And in that Unity
script, they're saying--
they're trying to be nice and
not block rendering and saying,
wait until next frame.
But this is causing their
load times to suffer a lot.
There's probably a
good one and a half,
two seconds they could
get back by not doing this
during the actual load,
just because there is so
much free time on that thread.
And that is the bottleneck
for the load here.
There's actually very
little I/O done here.
One of the things we see
in general on Android
is that you're
generally not I/O bound,
especially on high-end devices.
Low-end devices, really low-end
devices are very different.
But if you're talking mid- or
high-end in the past few years,
flash performance has increased
dramatically to the point
that it's faster than a
lot of desktop machines.
And you're not that I/O
bound most of the time.
The biggest bottleneck
is definitely the CPU.
And that's what we see--
even in this very
graphically intensive game,
it's bottlenecked by the CPU.
Let's look at gameplay, because
there's some interesting stuff
there, too.
So once again, there's
the surface view.
And you can see it's taking back
and forth in the middle there.
And overall it
looks pretty good.
I have very few
complaints about this.
But I can always be
pretty nit-picky,
so let's find something
that is wrong.
So it did drop a frame
in the middle here.
There is a place where it should
have rendered a frame and it
just didn't.
No frame was ready
for SurfaceFlinger,
so the app probably did not
complete a frame on time.
So let's scroll down and
see what happened in the app
to make it not complete
a frame on time.
So here is the Unity
GfxDevice thread,
which is actually dispatching
the render clause.
And it looks like at one
point it just skipped.
So it just missed--
something missed a
deadline somewhere.
And it decided, hey,
just drop the frame.
We're not going to make it.
So let's look at the Unity main
thread and see what's going on.
Aha, there is the smoking gun.
Immediately before that dropped
frame from the Unity GfxDevice,
we see a bunch of I/O on
the Unity main thread.
That's a little weird.
I wonder why that happened.
But then I scrolled
up and realized
that is exactly when I
touched the screen to trigger
some special thing in the game.
So my guess is that I
pressed a button in the game.
There was something on the
disk that was not loaded.
And even though I just--
throughput is really high.
It's still disk latency,
so it takes a while for--
you know, even if
it was 20 bytes,
it will still take a while to
get those 20 bytes off of disk.
That blocked the
Unity main thread,
which, in turn, caused the Unity
GfxDevice thread to not render
a frame.
And that was seen
as a frame drop.
But overall this is
actually a pretty good game.
It's running pretty close
to a solid 30 FPS, I think.
But it is actually maintaining
it and working really well.
But there's always something you
can improve with performance.
You can always be
harsher on yourself.
But that's the data we
get out of Systrace.
It's exactly what happened.
And it allows you
to tie it together
across the system to figure
out what actually went wrong.
And coupled with the new support
on Android P for triggering
a trace on device,
it's easier than ever
to actually spot
performance issues
and figure out what's going on.
So, yeah, I guess questions.
AUDIENCE: You just mentioned
that most of the games
are not I/O bound, right?
TIM MURRAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So basically
it's true when
the assets are uncompressed, but
the APK is compressed itself.
Of course you can store
some of the frames
without this deflate
compression there.
But in that case, the size
is going to probably bypass
the 100 megabyte limit.
TIM MURRAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you want to
read 20 bytes from the disk,
it's not like reading
20 bytes from the disk.
You have to read the whole block
of the zip compressed file,
then decompress it.
And then you have access
to these 20 bytes.
And that actually is something
which you probably can't even
solve with the higher
speeds of the flash.
TIM MURRAY: Sure.
But with the flash, I
mean, even the latency
is still poor compared to--
I mean, it's not like
spinning disk poor.
But compared to something
that's already in memory,
it's dramatically higher.
And you're always going
to read some fixed amount.
I forgot what the
minimum granularity
you can read from the flash is.
But you're always going to read
some block size from the flash.
So it doesn't
really matter if you
have 4K to read or
three bytes to read,
you're going to read
the same amount of data.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, there
are multiple layers
of caching everywhere.
TIM MURRAY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you have to
invalidate all the caches,
then read from
the flash, have it
loaded into the
cache of the flash,
and then throw the file levels.
Do you think it makes sense to
store more assets uncompressed
in order to reduce
the whole overhead?
Sorry.
So talking from
the perspective is
like, on iOS, the assets
are stored uncompressed
on the device, right?
TIM MURRAY: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: And that could
be one of the reasons
why the loading performance
or the performance when
you are loading on Nextel
or something like that
is much higher,
because you don't
have to uncompressed stuff.
TIM MURRAY: So I
don't actually think
that's the reason for
the difference in loading
performance.
It looks pretty much
like the difference
in single-threaded
CPU performance.
It matches pretty closely
with the difference
in single-threaded
CPU performance.
What we see, I mean,
especially in Unity apps,
is that Unity apps
on 5.6 or something
like that are still primarily
single-threaded, especially
around load times.
And they're CPU
bound on Android.
I bet they're still probably CPU
bound a lot of the time on iOS.
IOS generally has higher
single-threaded CPU
performance, so load
times are better.
So more multithreading--
I mean, we've got
eight-core devices
that are pretty common in
the kind of mid- and high-end
of Android now.
More multithreading is
better, essentially.
AUDIENCE: Right,
but then you get
into power and thermal issues.
TIM MURRAY: You do.
But you-- to some extent, yeah.
I mean, the CPU is the dominant
power consumer on the system.
It's not the display.
It's not the GPU.
It's the CPU.
So you do have to be careful
with CPU power consumption.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.